[SPEAKER_02]: Welcome back, Benjamin, to part two of Paragliding Atlas. And first thing that comes to my mind when it's all about storytelling is that how
[SPEAKER_02]: do you basically start building a narrative? Let's say you're Guinness World Record. Fly Menorca has a very deep meaning behind it. The way you
[SPEAKER_02]: explain the migration of the butterflies and the challenges they face and everything. So when it comes to developing a narrative, how does
[SPEAKER_02]: your process for that one look like and how do you do it? Sure. There's a few different approaches that I can imagine someone going into
[SPEAKER_00]: something like this. And... So there's three to be precise that I can imagine. One is, okay, we really want to do this thing. Let's paraglide
[SPEAKER_00]: from Mexico to Canada. That sounds cool. And so let's just do this thing, right? Okay, done. Now we're looking at that footage and we're saying,
[SPEAKER_00]: okay, what's interesting? What's relevant? Where are some parallels? How can we weave this into a story? And then start building that
[SPEAKER_00]: narrative on the editing floor, right? Because you still haven't presented anything to the world. How are you going to make it mean
[SPEAKER_00]: something to people beyond just, hey, I've got a bit of an ego and I'm going to do this thing. to be overly simplistic. Then there's the other
[SPEAKER_00]: approach, which is to say, I can't start unless I know how the intro is gonna go, how the middle is gonna go, where all the twists are gonna be,
[SPEAKER_00]: what are the ups, what are the downs, how is it gonna conclude, what's the moral? Okay, so now here's the second option where we've constructed a
[SPEAKER_00]: story the way you might screenwrite like a Hollywood film.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then you go ahead and you try to have your experience and you try to have that experience of paragliding from Mexico to Canada and actually
[SPEAKER_00]: meet all of those checkboxes. Like, okay, got that scene. Okay, got that scene. Oh, yeah, I was hungry right there. Okay, got that scene done. So
[SPEAKER_00]: now you're just going to slap it together, again, the way that they would in a commercial sort of documentary made for television where...
[SPEAKER_00]: That's how they do it, without elaborating on why. And then there's the middle ground, which is that you have some inspiration. In my case, for
[SPEAKER_00]: this project, it was the monarch butterfly. I discovered them, although I grew up with them in Canada, and they were just a
[SPEAKER_00]: run-of-the-mill standard butterfly that you wouldn't bat an eyelash. The finding them in Mexico and then realizing that they actually flew
[SPEAKER_00]: there, that blew my mind. That blew my mind because I thought nothing of them, but I would think highly of anything that could fly from even a
[SPEAKER_00]: bird. Nevermind the equivalent of a post-it note. the Monarch butterfly, I would have a tremendous amount of respect for a goose that
[SPEAKER_00]: did that. Here we have this little piece of paper doing that. And with an accuracy that I don't even, for the viewers that don't know this, the
[SPEAKER_00]: Monarch butterfly, a little butterfly is flying three, 4,000 kilometers per hour. from one country across an entire other country
[SPEAKER_00]: down to the southern part of this continent and landing, like top landing on a very specific mountain where they've never been before,
[SPEAKER_00]: their parents had never been before, their parents had never been before, but their parents had been born to have that kind of pinpoint
[SPEAKER_00]: accuracy on top of this monumentous, seemingly impossible, even now when I think about it, project. is so inspiring to me as a cross-country
[SPEAKER_00]: pilot who just desperately tries to tag waypoints on a flight that I planned that feels near impossible to me. So there, without going off
[SPEAKER_00]: too far, I'm saying that is my inspiration. I am motivated. What can I do to try and experience something of what they've experienced? Okay, now
[SPEAKER_00]: we have the inspiration. Now we have the general idea. Now let's go and live it. And yeah, of course, we can try to find parallels while we're
[SPEAKER_00]: going and make some notes and do some vlogs about that. But let's take the original idea, not be too attached to how the project is going to go. Have
[SPEAKER_00]: it go however it goes. Again, this is a part of not having too much pressure on oneself. And then... look at all of the parallels that we can
[SPEAKER_00]: draw, all of the exciting points that we should offer to our viewers, and just mash them together into an hour and a half, whatever it's gonna be,
[SPEAKER_00]: to try and create something that is inspiring and easy enough to watch. That's what I found works. It's worth saying, because you probably
[SPEAKER_00]: won't ask, i've tried both of the other methods just doing something and then trying to put the story together at the end that that works but it can
[SPEAKER_00]: seem it can seem a little bit amateur or at least i feel that way maybe it's because those were my earlier works but then the other extreme where you
[SPEAKER_00]: literally have a storyboard And you try to check off those epic scenes because if you can achieve this up and this down and this twist, that
[SPEAKER_00]: you're going to have something just that is sensational. That never works. There are films and films that I have shot or half shot that no one
[SPEAKER_00]: will ever see because I tried to do them that way to save time, to create better content, and they seem so fake and they're not interesting to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do not want to put energy into them. They're inauthentic and I feel like they would seem inauthentic to a viewer. Got it. I think you put it across
[SPEAKER_02]: beautifully. And I think just for the information of our audiences, for those who are interested in checking out Benjamin's work, just Google
[SPEAKER_02]: him up or head over to benjaminjordan.com and you see all the magic out there put at clicks. Yeah, just absolutely. Just benjaminjordan.com,
[SPEAKER_00]: like Michael Jordan's brother. Benjamin, benjaminjordan.com, that is where you want to find anything that I feel proud of that's come up in
[SPEAKER_00]: the last 15, 20 years. All right, great. I think we've talked about building a narrative and finding a purpose and how to doing it right and
[SPEAKER_02]: making sure it reaches the audience that we intend to. I'm just wondering, Benjamin, when you were working on all of these, and you did
[SPEAKER_02]: explain it a little bit, not to put any time expectation around it, but When it comes to putting together a visual project, what has an average
[SPEAKER_02]: timeline from the start to the finish look like for you? And if you can talk us a little bit about behind the scenes and budgeting and all of
[SPEAKER_02]: that, so that anybody who is willing to get into this gets an overall idea from someone like you who has made it and realized these things. Okay. So
[SPEAKER_00]: hopefully your audience is getting a sense. I certainly am getting the sense as I say a lot of these things out loud that my MO is really to try to
[SPEAKER_00]: keep as much pressure off of myself as possible. So my timelines may be way stretched out versus the current expectations of people that may be
[SPEAKER_00]: looking at doing similar things. But I like, so overall, big picture, I like to spread out projects by two years. And there's a few reasons for
[SPEAKER_00]: that. I found that works best when you need to do four parts. Pre-production, which I consider conceptualization of a concept.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry, so redundancy there. Birth of a concept. Search for support, which is, I gotta say in parentheses, that's not a requirement. right if
[SPEAKER_00]: people want to get on board that's great if people don't want to get on board it's what's perfect is if projects can happen with or without
[SPEAKER_00]: sponsorship and ironically sponsors are more likely to support something that doesn't need them versus something that is requires
[SPEAKER_00]: them that is the i don't want to go off on a tangent but i've learned that painfully over time that If people don't think that you need them, then
[SPEAKER_00]: they start to feel like they need you. The same way is if I had a project that already had a whole bunch of sponsorship, it would be really easy to
[SPEAKER_00]: get additional sponsors. because those sponsors recognize ultimately, not that they're having FOMO and that they wanna be like all
[SPEAKER_00]: the other sponsors, but what they recognize is this person's already has the support to do what it is that they wanna do with or without me. And
[SPEAKER_00]: so this is actually a good place to invest. And so that can also apply to having no sponsors for a project, no support for a project, that they
[SPEAKER_00]: recognize that this project is going to happen with or without because the requirements are well within your means. And so that's just a side
[SPEAKER_00]: note, but so that's a part of pre-production. So you got your idea, you're putting together some materials perhaps to get some support.
[SPEAKER_00]: That could take six months, especially if you're working another job or you have some other obligations like family. Then you have your
[SPEAKER_00]: project, which not to spoil anyone's dreams, but that's usually the quickest part of the whole process of this two-year cycle that I like to
[SPEAKER_00]: look at, which can take anywhere from as long as five months, six months for this fly monarca to as little as a few weeks, which was the time it took
[SPEAKER_00]: me to shoot The Boy Who Flies in Malawi, Africa. teaching the first person to paraglide there. And then after that, then you've got another
[SPEAKER_00]: six months, let's say of editing and your photos, writing articles, editing a film. And then, okay, so you've used, let's just say six
[SPEAKER_00]: months, six months and not, let's not even count the time for the expedition. Now, if you actually want to monetize that thing that
[SPEAKER_00]: you've created, you need to be able to promote that and possibly do what I have enjoyed doing, which is going on my own film tours where I'm driving
[SPEAKER_00]: around and I'm presenting and I'm doing Q and A's and I feel I really enjoy doing that. And they can be lucrative economically, but even just being
[SPEAKER_00]: a part of film festivals, et cetera, et cetera, all these things take time. You submit today and then hopefully they accept your film in five
[SPEAKER_00]: months and then three months later it's on the screen. So right there, that's like a year. And while that's happening, you've entered your
[SPEAKER_00]: next six month cycle to begin preparations for your next project. So just in terms of being realistic for me to do this as a professional and be
[SPEAKER_00]: able to pay my way through life with these projects, I need to give myself that kind of time on either end of the actual expedition in order to do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I would say as a side effect, Giving myself that kind of time, it also allows me to have renewed passion when I get going on my next
[SPEAKER_00]: project. This is versus maybe what I would have imagined and maybe what a lot of other people would imagine, which is like, oh, you got 10 years,
[SPEAKER_00]: you could do 10 expeditions, you could do something every summer, every paragliding season. I could do something every paragliding season,
[SPEAKER_00]: but if I did that, I don't think that I would be able to do it professionally. at least not without an entire team of people around me
[SPEAKER_00]: doing all of the film editing and publicity and all of that kind of work. I would literally just have to be the athlete, which I'm just not in that
[SPEAKER_00]: position. And I don't think I would really like to be in that position. It would feel too much like a job. So that's, I think that answers your
[SPEAKER_00]: question just in terms of the flow and the realistic expectations. It does very well. And thank you once again for explaining it so well. Like
[SPEAKER_02]: you're a podcaster's dream, man. I ask one question and you answer all the side questions by yourself. I love being a podcaster's dream. I'll
[SPEAKER_00]: add that to my portfolio. Go ahead, man. I'll vouch for it. If you need a testimonial, hit me up. I'll write the best one ever. Yeah, I feel like I
[SPEAKER_02]: want to go on a tiny bit of tangent here before switching on to the next point is that very new generation in today's world is increasing from
[SPEAKER_02]: digital media and be with any kind of content on YouTube or Instagram or short form, long form, horizontal, vertical, because I think TikTok.
[SPEAKER_02]: recently started horizontal content as well usually at an average of course this is very subjective depending upon how many projects you
[SPEAKER_02]: have and how much success you get with them but at an average what kind of revenue generations do projects like these look at can you end up buying
[SPEAKER_02]: a small car can you end up buying a living off it for a few months in a very frugal manner or just a ballpark figure so that our audiences get an idea
[SPEAKER_02]: like what they are getting into if they want to Well, okay. So that's a great question. And I feel like in order for that to be, to resonate with
[SPEAKER_00]: as many people as possible, I really shouldn't dive into, what's the right word? Like static figures? Because... Somehow it feels
[SPEAKER_00]: unprofessional, but also I feel like it feels like it would alienate someone who's on either side of that. Someone who might think that's way
[SPEAKER_00]: too much or someone who might probably most people would think that's not enough. I can't believe that he survives on that. And so let's just
[SPEAKER_00]: say it's always more than I think. can generate but it's probably not been enough to keep me out of what a lot of people who are working other
[SPEAKER_00]: like hardcore nine-to-five jobs that they either love or don't love would think is much beyond the poverty level I had my my mom growing up my
[SPEAKER_00]: mom was a high school teacher and Way back then, this is in the 80s, I remember her thinking that she needed to raise our family. She made
[SPEAKER_00]: about 40K Canadian per year. And again, we've had a lot of inflation since then. But for a lot of my life, I haven't had to support a family. And
[SPEAKER_00]: that's all been by design because I recognized that I was going to go through this period of not earning very much and having to eat a lot of
[SPEAKER_00]: beans and rice and living in the school bus, as I described in the interview prior in order to get by. I've always been able to get by with
[SPEAKER_00]: the support that I've gotten. I'd say at first from the community at large, for instance, The Boy Who Flies, this is a film that I shot in,
[SPEAKER_00]: pardon me, 2011. about traveling to Malawi to teach children how to build kites from random pieces of garbage. And then ultimately found a
[SPEAKER_00]: guy who wanted to learn to paraglide. And then we have this inspiring story of him becoming his country's first paraglider pilot. Great
[SPEAKER_00]: film. Also, it's my first film. Monetarily, that was probably the most successful film I've ever had in terms of prizes won from film
[SPEAKER_00]: festivals, in terms of licensing for television, in terms of people buying hard DVDs and digital downloads. That was great. That allowed me
[SPEAKER_00]: not only to go back to Malawi and even have enough extra money to go back there and start a paragliding school there and a community center
[SPEAKER_00]: there, but it, or I should say piggyback on a community center that existed there, but to allow people to go there and paraglide with people
[SPEAKER_00]: there and teach more people to paraglide there. It allowed me to live for probably three years. while I worked on my next project, which became
[SPEAKER_00]: XBC, Paragliding from Vancouver to Calgary. The film's called Strong the Wind Blows. It's pretty cool. You should check it out. So I've always
[SPEAKER_00]: been able to get by. But I think that what's important to say is that I wouldn't have been able to get by had I continued to live the lifestyle
[SPEAKER_00]: that I was living prior to embarking on this journey. Had I continued to rent the same nice apartment? Had I continued to feed myself the same
[SPEAKER_00]: kind of food? Had I continued to have dinner guests over every week and be feeding them some fine foods? Had I done all that stuff? Had I not moved
[SPEAKER_00]: into the school bus and really humbled myself? None of that would have worked out for me. I wouldn't have been able to put the time in and I
[SPEAKER_00]: wouldn't be here talking to you right now. Now, I would say a relatively small portion of the income comes from the audience, which is sad
[SPEAKER_00]: because I like that idea of that's the community that supports me. The community does support me, but over time now as I've had more success,
[SPEAKER_00]: but also just had more eyeballs, I've gotten the attention of people who can benefit from advertising inside of what I do, which was always the
[SPEAKER_00]: goal was to create what I dubbed authentic advertising, which is giving people an opportunity to present their brands inside of a story that is
[SPEAKER_00]: true as opposed to fake. What I used to create in my past life as a fashion photographer, as a commercial photographer in the city of Toronto,
[SPEAKER_00]: which was inauthentic advertising, which people are giving me a wad of cash to create a whole scenario that never would have existed if that wad
[SPEAKER_00]: of cash hadn't existed. And to create a picture of someone having a good time or a picture of someone being sexy or someone being badass or
[SPEAKER_00]: whatever in order to sell a product. People are looking at that picture and they're getting on board with that brand because they're having an
[SPEAKER_00]: emotion. But that emotion is triggered by something that never ever would have happened had a company not completely manipulated a scene in
[SPEAKER_00]: order to create it. Sorry if I'm all over the place here. I wanted to stop doing that work in Toronto as a faking it. That's the thing. It didn't
[SPEAKER_00]: feel good to me. Because I realized through, it was actually the images from that skateboarding event that I called the board meeting that were
[SPEAKER_00]: so powerful that I realized, wait a second, these images are so powerful that they're getting more people to come out, more people to come out.
[SPEAKER_00]: People are taking action based on pictures of things that are really happening. And I get it. That sounds to people like, yeah, dude, what's
[SPEAKER_00]: the big deal? You're just having an adventure and photographing it. Yeah, dude, you're just having an adventure and you're filming it. But
[SPEAKER_00]: at the time, I could have never imagined it at the time. For me, pictures were all just about creating a false image to influence a viewer into
[SPEAKER_00]: making a financial choice to engage with a product or service. That's how I started. And it didn't feel good. And when I realized that I was
[SPEAKER_00]: making pictures and I was art directing really, because I would have these events and then I would be directing 15 photographers. What kind
[SPEAKER_00]: of film to use? What kind of shots to get this shot? And I'm creating these powerful images of people skateboarding in white dress shirts and
[SPEAKER_00]: neckties through a busy city, congesting traffic. I'm creating power greater than I could create shooting for L'Oreal or shooting for Nike
[SPEAKER_00]: with these fake settings where I've rented all these lights and these makeup artists and stylists. How can I take that power? It feels so good
[SPEAKER_00]: to create this true, authentic power and now offer that privilege to a brand because that brand is willing to say, hey, you know what? We
[SPEAKER_00]: support what you're doing. And here's a wad of cash. Keep at it. And that's been great because that kind of support What it's allowed me to do
[SPEAKER_00]: is it's allowed me to not be so concerned about whether or not I am able to generate enough film sales or whether or not my film is perfect festival
[SPEAKER_00]: material and not have to rely on those sources of income as much and just know that there are businesses that are willing to get behind me
[SPEAKER_00]: regardless because they appreciate the message and they appreciate that people are seeing this and that they agree that this is a great way to
[SPEAKER_00]: advertise and reach people in an authentic way. I love it, man. But just to illustrate this point a little more, can you pick up any example from
[SPEAKER_02]: any of your projects so that our audiences can relate or get an overview of how this actually works when you go out in real world where you have had
[SPEAKER_02]: an inherent goal for the brand and sold them the story that, hey, this is how it's going to be represented and that's why you should support?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure. So I come up with an idea. I think to myself, okay, so let's go, let's say, okay, I'm gonna fly a paraglider across Canada, powered
[SPEAKER_00]: paraglider across Canada. So back in the day, who's gonna see this? Who's gonna be moved by it? Who's gonna care about it? Okay. probably a
[SPEAKER_00]: lot of kids are gonna care about it because what kid doesn't wanna fly? Let's just be honest, right? Like in some capacity, not to sound cliche,
[SPEAKER_00]: but like the dream of flying, I feel like we have these dreams, especially when we're young for some reason, I don't know what it is, but
[SPEAKER_00]: it happens. And when I was a kid, long before I discovered paragliding, like flying seemed like a really good idea to me. Agreed. So am I gonna
[SPEAKER_00]: fly... literally by the seat of my pants with a little fan attached to my back across Canada. Who's going to care about that the most? Kids. Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: How can I connect with kids inside of doing that? Okay. Why don't I do this to support children so that adults who are responsible for children
[SPEAKER_00]: feel like incorporating me into something that they're doing so that I, and then ultimately by virtue of that, that I can actually reach those
[SPEAKER_00]: children. Okay, so now, okay, I'm going to paraglide across Canada, but I'm not just going to paraglide across Canada, powered paraglide. I'm
[SPEAKER_00]: going to do it to support children. Okay, when am I going to do it? I'm going to do it in the summer. What are children doing in the summer?
[SPEAKER_00]: They're going to summer camp. okay, I'm gonna do this to support children going to summer camp. Does that feel good to me? Yes, it does
[SPEAKER_00]: feel good to me. I went to summer camp and I went to summer camp when I was a kid that wasn't entirely paid for by my family. It was actually
[SPEAKER_00]: partially paid for by funding received from either the government or some sort of outside donors. So let me create something that gives back
[SPEAKER_00]: to that. That feels good to me. I can actually get behind that and put extra oomph into that because of the value that I got there. okay, so now
[SPEAKER_00]: we're going to paraglide across Canada. We're going to be interested in having kids see this, and we're going to work with kids in order to make
[SPEAKER_00]: that happen. Okay, cool. We're going to land at summer camps. We're going to give inspiring conversations to children about achieving
[SPEAKER_00]: their dreams. While we're there, why don't we organize them into giant shapes on the ground, take pictures of those shapes to create something
[SPEAKER_00]: that's visual, that speaks a thousand words with the one picture, which is kids having a good time at summer camp. That's what this is all about
[SPEAKER_00]: now. Finally, Who's interested? Who's aligned with summer camp? Who else is giving to summer camp right now? In Canada, people may or may not
[SPEAKER_00]: know our stereotypical coffee chain, Tim Hortons. That's their thing. They are the company that aligns themselves with that statement,
[SPEAKER_00]: giving to kids going to summer camp. They have every, whatever, every year, like kids go to camp week or something like that, where some
[SPEAKER_00]: portion of every donut, every coffee that you buy goes to their charity that supports kids going to camp. So finally, now I'm going to design
[SPEAKER_00]: this project. to meet their existing branding so that they can see this project as a one-stop shop to increase what they're already doing. They
[SPEAKER_00]: just need to throw five, 10, $20,000 at it. I'll give them options in order to buy into this additional branding that they can use on top of
[SPEAKER_00]: what they're already doing, on top of what they've already got the okay to spend money on. And that should be our path of least resistance. Are
[SPEAKER_00]: you following me, Sam? 100%. I think this is, I have to say, take notes, boys and girls, because you are literally giving out one of the most
[SPEAKER_02]: effective blueprints in how to make it happen. And I feel like you've just given out a whole small little masterclass and then finding
[SPEAKER_02]: sponsorships to make your dreams realize. And I don't know about how many people in the audience are actually going ahead and doing it, but I
[SPEAKER_02]: definitely am taking notes and making it happen. This seems like a beautiful way to give back something to the sponsor and also have
[SPEAKER_02]: something for yourself and make your dreams a reality while maintaining a fine balance. Love it. It's worth saying, happy to hear
[SPEAKER_00]: that. It's worth saying that in the end, Tim Hortons was not interested in this project. The short of it is that they essentially said to me after
[SPEAKER_00]: much door knocking and presenting to them virtually that they already have a team of people working on this and they're content with the amount
[SPEAKER_00]: of fundraising that they do and that's working for their business. They don't need any extra fundraising to occur and they don't need to
[SPEAKER_00]: incorporate with any external businesses in order to do what they're doing. which was very disheartening for me at the time, because I'm
[SPEAKER_00]: thinking to myself, what do you mean you don't wanna raise an additional 100,000 or possibly a million or $5 million by piggybacking on this
[SPEAKER_00]: record-breaking flight across Canada that kids are gonna love and that we could get tons of media around if we just would hook up. But in the end,
[SPEAKER_00]: it just didn't make business sense to them. to do that and as painful as that was, trust me, it was painful to spend months and months basically
[SPEAKER_00]: designing this project to be exactly what they would want. This is where expectation and disappointment come in that conversation. To hear
[SPEAKER_00]: from them, hey, we don't need to raise more money, good luck. Because I did that work, I still had the template And I could still present that to
[SPEAKER_00]: other businesses, which did come on board. And they found their own reasons, even if I couldn't necessarily see the exact reason. And I
[SPEAKER_00]: didn't have anywhere near the support that I need, but I did have enough in order to make it happen. And it was important for me to have that vision
[SPEAKER_00]: and to have the idea of Tim Hortons in this case supporting, because it allowed me to really flesh out the whole thing and really create that
[SPEAKER_00]: sales package. So that's two parts. One, that's how you would get a brand like importance in an ideal world. But this isn't an ideal world. And in
[SPEAKER_00]: the end, your failure is still a success if you can frame it that way that you recognize that without them without the inspiration of working for
[SPEAKER_00]: them or working with them you wouldn't have had all of this come together and look like this nice tidy package that other people will buy and that
[SPEAKER_00]: you yourself as an athlete and a filmmaker you buy because you can see how beautiful it is right Got it, man. I'm so glad I used the word masterclass
[SPEAKER_02]: for this because, of course, you gave the blueprint on how to do things, and you also gave the blueprint in the second part of what to do when
[SPEAKER_02]: things don't go right. So moving forward, I would want to come to the most important part of putting together a project, which I'm pretty sure a
[SPEAKER_02]: lot of our audience members are going to be curious about, and that is filming in flight. I would love to have you talk over what kind of camera
[SPEAKER_02]: gear you shoot, what kind of shot selections do you do. Because to me, when GoPro and all the mounts and the selfie sticks came across, they
[SPEAKER_02]: looked like a pretty big safety hazard for me. where they could snag lines and one collapse could take away your distraction and send you
[SPEAKER_02]: scrambling for handling the selfie stick and everything. Of course, it has evolved over a period of time and now cameras are shooting in 8K,
[SPEAKER_02]: which can fit in your pocket and everything. How have you navigated this aspect of filming in flight and what's your usual go-to setup in making
[SPEAKER_02]: all the possible magical shots come together? Sure. It's a big subject. Because...
[SPEAKER_00]: All right. Filming yourself in general, like nevermind paragliding, because it applies to paragliding. for me, sorry, I'll say filming
[SPEAKER_00]: myself requires a lot of self-discipline because so often I'm, at least ideally, I'm doing something that I would be doing if the camera wasn't
[SPEAKER_00]: there. And so that means that I'm just excited about what it is that I'm doing. And at some point, when you're trying to create hundreds of hours
[SPEAKER_00]: of footage to be able to edit it down into one hour, an hour and a half of really great footage, you got to get the camera out a lot. And so you might
[SPEAKER_00]: plan on walking up this mountain and averaging five kilometers an hour. But the truth is, if you want to be able to present that to people later,
[SPEAKER_00]: you have to plan on moving at maybe more like two kilometers an hour because of all the time it takes to run ahead, get a tripod out, get the
[SPEAKER_00]: camera running, make sure the batteries are good, get the audio going. And so...
[SPEAKER_00]: That takes a lot of self-discipline for me to slow myself down, to create this stuff. And it especially takes that self-discipline when I'm not
[SPEAKER_00]: feeling great. Because when I'm not feeling great, I don't have that skip in my step. Like maybe it's raining. Maybe I just had a bad flight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe I'm really tired. Maybe I'm super dehydrated. That's happened. And all I can do is think about getting to the next potential lake or
[SPEAKER_00]: stream. But I have to realize that those moments where I'm really not doing well, those are vital in filmmaking because I
[SPEAKER_00]: tend to get the camera out when I'm doing great and I just love the world and I love myself and I love my project and I wanna share it. But without
[SPEAKER_00]: the sad, awkward, difficult, painful moments in between, that becomes very redundant. in it in an edited piece and so that's the first thing is
[SPEAKER_00]: just to recognize like hey it should be really easy in theory but in practice it's just actually really hard and it requires a kind of
[SPEAKER_00]: self-discipline that I barely have and often don't so now moving on to paragliding It can be dangerous to be preoccupied with cameras. It can
[SPEAKER_00]: be dangerous to have things strapped to us that can impact our lines or our reserve system or whatever. So a lot of that thought needs to be put
[SPEAKER_00]: into that. And I feel like safety is top notch, not top notch, is of the highest order. And it's important to find things that Partly for the
[SPEAKER_00]: reasons of that if things are hard, we won't do them like I was talking about on the ground. But also if things require too much time or thought,
[SPEAKER_00]: they're not really safe when you're dangling from 30 string above a mountain. You need to have them be really easy. And you need to be able to
[SPEAKER_00]: do them blindfolded. So as far as filming while paragliding, coming up with creative ideas that maybe you haven't seen before, or maybe you
[SPEAKER_00]: have, but that are really easy to achieve. Like you can do them in 10 seconds, 15 seconds. In terms of setting them up, often I don't launch
[SPEAKER_00]: with my cameras out. I have to release them once I'm paragliding. That's really important is to have things that you can do quickly so that you
[SPEAKER_00]: don't, it doesn't require a ton of self-discipline to get them out and then likely bring them back in before you land. But also that don't
[SPEAKER_00]: require a ton of time because you don't usually have that much time. I usually don't have that much time where I feel like I can fly without
[SPEAKER_00]: having my hands on my toggles and be completely in the game as far as, okay, where's my bomb out? Where's my next thermal, right? Yeah, that
[SPEAKER_02]: makes a lot of sense, I think. Have you been just using action cams for this or have you ever switched to what is a single lens DSLR or something
[SPEAKER_02]: like that? Or what kind of hardware do you usually use to tell your stories as the technology has evolved? Okay, yeah, sure. I can talk
[SPEAKER_00]: about that. So on my last... film that I've released so far. Fly Monarcha, I have a, it's the Sony RX100 fourth edition I used. I've
[SPEAKER_00]: actually been using that one for almost 10 years. I keep buying the same one because I break them. I wear them out. They shoot 4K. They are like
[SPEAKER_00]: mini DSLR. They have a lot of manual options. It's not the best that you're ever going to see, but it's... way better than a phone or at least
[SPEAKER_00]: phones at the time or GoPro or what have you. So that in combination with the tripod is how I do, I would say 75% of my terrestrial stuff. The rest
[SPEAKER_00]: would be using GoPros on selfie sticks, gimbals and stuff like that. And then in the sky, it's pretty much entirely GoPro footage with the
[SPEAKER_00]: exception of As you'll see in Fly Monarcha and a little bit in the Endless Chain, but really in Fly Monarcha, where I had the privilege of having my
[SPEAKER_00]: now wife accompany me as a filmmaker on her own autonomously in a van, she would hike up and capture a lot of very helpful drone footage of me. So I
[SPEAKER_00]: don't want to forget to say that. But as far as me, that was separate from what I was doing, right? So what I'm doing is GoPros. I rely on three shots
[SPEAKER_00]: that I really like that I can set up pretty quick. The easiest is a 360 cam that I jam. So like the GoPro 360, whatever it's called, I just jam that
[SPEAKER_00]: into the flip plate. That's the quickest one. I have another one on a arm that articulates by two hinges, so it's got three sections. And then on
[SPEAKER_00]: that, there's a gimbal and then another GoPro that's shooting me, but I can also turn the gimbal around to shoot forward or to the side. Both of
[SPEAKER_00]: those I can activate by hand in terms of starting and stopping them. And then finally, the most complex one for me to get out is a, let's just call
[SPEAKER_00]: it a follow cam. I think that would be the... accepted term for that which i keep in my harness in the side pocket and then once i feel very
[SPEAKER_00]: comfortable and i'm at some point in the flight that feels like it really needs to be documented that way i'll release that and that'll fly behind
[SPEAKER_00]: me usually on the left side it's biased towards the left wing tip is where i'm comfortable with it and i'll pay that out after I've launched. And
[SPEAKER_00]: then I'll, I actually have a thing that I can bring it back in when I'm landing, because sometimes you don't want something like that out
[SPEAKER_00]: there when you're landing, partly because it'll break, but mostly because I'm terrified of having it get caught on a branch or something
[SPEAKER_00]: like that. And then causing a deflation. That one runs on a, I think it uses Bluetooth, it's either wifi or Bluetooth. I'm not sure, but it's
[SPEAKER_00]: just like the standard GoPro remote that you can, I have that on my cockpit. And so those are the three shots for me, plus whatever my wife
[SPEAKER_00]: was able to capture on our last film with the drone. And then also audio. So the same little... It's called the Zoom H1. I don't know if they make
[SPEAKER_00]: them anymore. Maybe it's H1N. But... anything I was is better than what you can get on your camera. It's just a little recorder. I'll have a lapel
[SPEAKER_00]: mic with a little dead cat. They call it hairball that goes over the mic to cut down on wind. And I'll just clip that to either my buff or my inside of
[SPEAKER_00]: my jacket or something like that. And the sound is a little bit muffled, but I feel like that's a part of the authenticity of the shot. And so when
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm setting up my shots and, let's just say I get three out of three cameras running for a shot, I'll say, okay, flying over Mount Nemo, And
[SPEAKER_00]: then I'll just give a three clap and then that'll sync up all of my cameras and my audio. And then I'll be able to edit that later on. And I'll just
[SPEAKER_00]: talk about something. And ironically, usually I don't use any of the talking because it's just garbage, but it's there in case I do need it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And sometimes I do use it. And when it is good, it's really good. And that pretty much, that's the secret sauce. Yeah. I love it, man. I think
[SPEAKER_02]: sometimes the emotions that come out during the flight are one of the most authentic ones. So I think, as you said, when it's good, it's really
[SPEAKER_02]: good. It's the way to go. But Benjamin, what is the thing that makes you pull back the chase cam? What kind of mechanism do you use for that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because I've been using chase cam myself, but once I release it, I just basically have to wait until it goes to landing. Can you tell me
[SPEAKER_02]: something about that? Are you? Yeah. Okay. For the Endless Chain, which is the following film, I developed a two-part system. The most
[SPEAKER_00]: important part of it was I created a pulley system where now I, instead of just having the string, the fishing line run from the paraglider down to
[SPEAKER_00]: the chase cam, I have it run up to essentially what is just like a key ring or a little carabiner, like a baby carabiner on the paraglider. But I
[SPEAKER_00]: recommend using a key loop so that nothing can clip into it. And then that runs back down to my own carabiner from my paraglider. And I can release
[SPEAKER_00]: the camera. And then I can... pull that pulley and I pull it up, let's just say five, six, seven, eight meters. And then I attach a little pre-made
[SPEAKER_00]: loop on that fishing string that all of a sudden I see the loop and I attach that. Now, all of a sudden my camera is way higher than it was when I
[SPEAKER_00]: released it. And it's way higher than it would be able to be when I launch because it's too short. And then there's a third line and I guess a second
[SPEAKER_00]: line the second line goes from the camera also back to that same carabiner but it goes straight so when i am done flying or when i'm about
[SPEAKER_00]: to land and i want it back in i'll release that little loop on the pulley system so that now the camera falls back down to where it's too low to get a
[SPEAKER_00]: good shot i'm done shooting But it's long enough to make it all the way back to my harness. It's longer than my paragliding lines. And then I'll
[SPEAKER_00]: pull in the little string that goes directly from the follow cam to my harness. And then I'll put it back in the box. So basically, it's some
[SPEAKER_02]: kind of a triangle which goes between your lower surface and around the centers and around the C risers. That's right. Yes, it's a triangle. The
[SPEAKER_00]: top part has a pulley so I can adjust the height of where it flies. Damn, that's smart, man. You should try and sell that system because I'm
[SPEAKER_02]: pretty sure there are a lot of people out there looking for that kind of solutions. Got it. I think as we approach the end of this part of the
[SPEAKER_02]: episode, one challenge or one new aspect from what I see that has come up with content creation is that short form has picked up so much in today's
[SPEAKER_02]: world. We all know attention spans are reducing. Social media is to blame up to some extent and everything around it. But A lot of people are
[SPEAKER_02]: just settling in for short-form content and long-form isn't really becoming that viable anymore. So do you have any advice for the budding
[SPEAKER_02]: filmmakers or content creators? Of course, chasing hard, doing what makes sense to you is how it should be. But if you were to start now with all
[SPEAKER_02]: of these dreams in today's world and in today's age, how can somebody try and mimic your rate of success with the current industry trends and make
[SPEAKER_02]: sense with it? I don't know. In some ways, I feel like a bit of a dinosaur because when I look around me and I see the way people interact with...
[SPEAKER_00]: media, especially young people, I don't feel like I would have done very well as a human being growing up today. And that's not to sound resigned.
[SPEAKER_00]: I appreciate I am a dinosaur and dinosaurs don't understand that they're about to go extinct. I feel like there's a lot for me to learn to be
[SPEAKER_00]: able to properly answer that question. But I feel at the same time that Short form is because it works because people need a distraction, but
[SPEAKER_00]: they're really busy. So they don't, they want to lose themselves for five minutes because they have five minutes and they don't want to think
[SPEAKER_00]: about what's going on in their life and what they need to do, clean up their room, pay their bills, apologize to this person or go and do this,
[SPEAKER_00]: change the oil on their car, whatever it is that they don't want to think about that's in their head, but normally for five minutes. And so that
[SPEAKER_00]: serves a purpose. And I feel like there's always been a solution for that, whether it was the radio, the television, and people using those
[SPEAKER_00]: things for short periods of time. I appreciate, because of the way that this has happened, our attention spans, even as adults, have dwindled
[SPEAKER_00]: significantly. But I think that the key to so many of the things that I've done being as successful as they were is that somehow finding a way to
[SPEAKER_00]: really make people care, really make people care about it. And I actually can't even really take credit for realizing how important
[SPEAKER_00]: that was. Going back to skateboarding across Canada, I, as well as three other young gentlemen put this together and I can't even take credit for
[SPEAKER_00]: how it started because I got on board at the last minute as the documentary maker and essentially became the fourth skateboarder. We
[SPEAKER_00]: did this for the Canadian Breast Cancer Society and we raised a ton of money for breast cancer and a lot of awareness for breast cancer
[SPEAKER_00]: occurring more and more frequently in younger women who wouldn't have thought that they would be susceptible. And so there we are doing this
[SPEAKER_00]: thing. We've got this theme, these pink ribbons, Canadian Breast Cancer Society. And I remember on a message board from Toronto, I had
[SPEAKER_00]: published some content and some guy said, it was a nice comment from a friend of mine. He said, of course, Ben would be the one to skateboard
[SPEAKER_00]: across Canada and somehow find a way to make people care about it. That's what he said. And I realized like, hey, he's right. But also, he's
[SPEAKER_00]: looking at this and thinking, if I did this, nobody would care. Because truth be told, he could have also done it. He had the time. He had the
[SPEAKER_00]: skill. He would have had the desire to do all of this stuff. But he didn't have a way to make anyone care about why he was doing it. And here, it just
[SPEAKER_00]: fell into my lap. And then it became obvious to me after the fact. we were doing it for young women we were four 25 year old skateboarders
[SPEAKER_00]: skateboarding across canada to support the health of young women's breasts there is no more tongue-in-cheek project that i could have
[SPEAKER_00]: imagined being a part of but it really made people care it really made people think it really made people talk that i feel is the important part
[SPEAKER_00]: of every project If we take a look at this last one, the story of the monarch butterfly, there's no way to tell that short form. Maybe there
[SPEAKER_00]: is by someone else, but for me, that's a huge undertaking that they have to fly across the United States to Mexico and back again. And so in order
[SPEAKER_00]: for me to tell that story, the only way to tell that is is long form, and I think that someone who sees the trailer for that film will recognize
[SPEAKER_00]: that, whoa, this is huge. This isn't just someone going and flying above the clouds, and wow, that's pretty, and that has its place, and it will
[SPEAKER_00]: only take a few minutes to showcase that. I do have content like that, but these real stories that really make you think and that really take you to
[SPEAKER_00]: a new place like your podcasts, you can't get there in less than an hour. And I feel like it's important just to take a look at what we're doing and
[SPEAKER_00]: to ask yourself, why is someone going to care? And if we can't answer that, then we need to keep thinking about that. But as soon as we figure
[SPEAKER_00]: that out, that's when we can start to engage in telling a story that's going to ask someone for an hour of their life. Wow, man. It's like poetry
[SPEAKER_02]: in motion when you put it across so beautifully. Because it's all true, and it all makes a lot of sense. It's just a choice of realizing it and
[SPEAKER_02]: becoming aware of it, which is seemingly so easy. But again, we, even as adults, are reducing having our attention spans go haywire. Something
[SPEAKER_02]: as simple as that is often overlooked. But I think on that note, Benjamin, we pretty much have covered everything that we could wish for
[SPEAKER_02]: when it comes to flying and filming and on behalf of all my audience and the ones who are going to listen to the end to this in future i massive
[SPEAKER_02]: heartfelt thanks for sharing all this valuable gold for free of cost man and as i said in the beginning of the show one or two podcasts are not
[SPEAKER_02]: enough to cover all of your adventures so We on Power Mining Atlas would love to bring you back for a storytelling episode for all the other
[SPEAKER_02]: adventures you have chosen, but we're probably going to have to save that one for later. But for now, it's been an honor, man. Thanks a ton.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you so much for having me. This has been so great.